hey hold up
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by quavo he's a
rapper songwriter and record producer
you know as one third of the rap group
migos
his latest single straightening is out
now with the group's upcoming fourth
studio album culture 3 set to release on
june 11th
cuevo welcome to the show what's
happening what's happening how are you
around spicy food are you a man who
enjoys this hot sauce
i like a little bit of hot sauce
only on fish though well today
we're taking it on chicken are you ready
to get started
let's do it
[Music]
you got to eat the whole wing fans just
get mad
if like you take little nibbles but you
know some fans
[Laughter]
they should be happy with that one
[Music]
so it seems like everyone in
entertainment has been really challenged
on figuring out when to release
new projects and on the etc podcast with
kevin durant you talked about
how you can't just put out new music and
have the internet judge it from lockdown
why in particular with a group like
migos did you think that it was
important to wait until now to release a
project like culture three
because when we drop music we go
straight on the road we
touch the fans and and you perform in
front of them and you let them know
that this is how you perform the record
we normally come out and just
go crazy and jump around on stage so
every time we perform something it's
always going into clubs and clubs is
closed so it was tough so we was just
like all right cool we're gonna sit back
and
wait this thing gotta bless the people
later
and then you know the word culture it's
become kind of a buzzword that gets
thrown around a lot of times in
corporate boardrooms by people who have
no connection to it really what does the
word mean to you
we feel like we're leading by example
and we gave him the flow that
everybody using and everybody creating
new flows off of that flow we the
foundation so we the culture we
have bricks that are starting all this
new music right now
see i like all flats so i'm gonna just
go fifty percent
[Music]
all right cool so we can't have a cueva
interview without deep diving your
personal style which has been
highlighted on gq's best dressed man of
the week
more often than i can count yeah do you
remember running into jeff goldblum at
eve saint laurent a few years ago he
talked about it during his hot ones
interview
yeah man every time i see him though
he's super fresh i just seen him at um
the clippers game and he just
super fresh every time i see him and i
was like who that is what it is and they
told me i was like okay cool
it makes sense it makes sense but yeah
the drip is crazy pound for pound what
do you think is the best fit that you've
ever gotten off at a paris or new york
fashion week
i like how we pulled up in med galvin i
think it was the year of
versace i'm not mistaken that was crazy
i felt like we came best dressed that
time and then
speaking of versace and the versace
remix offset has a line where he says
you'd think i'm egyptian all this gold
on my body would it be
fair to say that the ancient pharaohs
would be like a style inspiration for
migos with the silk
the chains and the patterns for show of
course
um we young pharaohs we feel like we
young kings and
and we love gold and then finally what's
your favorite piece of jewelry that
you're wearing right now
i just i just put the uh the big boy on
the day of
gets flooded out ap um the the big pound
guy you know what i'm saying we say big
pound because
it's the m the million dollar watch and
i'm just kicking it i ain't want to put
no ice on because i know how hot these
wings are gonna be you know what i'm
saying
you feel me
[Music]
yeah i'm [ __ ] with that one and
that's kind of a little one with like a
kick so maybe you have like a good
hot sauce tolerance yeah no i gotta look
david beckham with it
kick it a little bit so i'm fascinated
by the early days of amigos when you
guys were recording songs off of a
microphone that you'd nailed to the
living room wall and then rapping over
beats that take off it downloaded off
soundclick
yeah what role did the song boosted up
play in the origin
the origin story of migos oh [ __ ] that
was um
that was one of our high school records
and um
at the time we we was we was migo gang
and we were trying to boost it up we
we was boosting [ __ ] up like
we outside i i see what i see what
you're saying there i see what you're
saying there so
and it was like um i grabbed this sheet
it was like a um
it was a bed sheet with whole like money
signs and coins and [ __ ]
i nailed that [ __ ] in the back and then
when i net in the back we used to shoot
videos in front of it and
just rap all day and take off reason why
his name take off because he used to do
everything in one take
movie maker you had to like record one
pass anybody messed up on one ad a
little anything we had to
start it all the way over and that's how
i take i got one tape because he'll do
his whole verse
and not mess up and we'll mess up and
have to start him over
how did that translate at school like
did making music at that age did that
and dear you did the kids more did it
make you more popular at school or what
effect did the music have there
everybody kind of laughed at me yeah
they kind of laughed at me you know
passing out to see these men take off on
the songs and then
that thing you know all set was like he
was the only one that was feeling it
he was the only one that was feeling hey
bro you rapping that [ __ ] so hard i'm
trying to
and then after that we would just put
them in the studio and
get them up to speed with us and then
you know it was it was
it was magic
[Music]
lost caliente barbacoa that do it
so during a complex interview that you
did with jinx in 2018 and the rest of
the quality control crew you talked
about an
urge to get into acting and here you are
three years later about to make your
feature film debut in a film called
wash me in the river alongside cast
members that include john malkovich and
robert de niro
did you get a chance on set to tell
robert de niro that you name checked him
and straightening
yeah i told him i told him he was like
you're like man i love it
that was right after right after um i
think we stayed in uh puerto rico for a
month
and um i was just recording there and
right after we came
back home from puerto rico i just went
in because i
was soaking all the watch me in the
river you know what i'm saying vibes up
you know i'm saying you got jack houston
you got my boy robert de niro and
those those are the scenes i was in with
so i was just soaking up gaming just
watching them and then when i had
i just dialed it up i had some [ __ ] to
say when i got home
what was his response to when you told
him that you named jacob
did one of those like soprano moves like
you know what i'm saying
good job appreciate it that's it
[Music]
that wasn't pleasant what's this ginger
goat
yeah yeah maybe the the ginger in there
or something maybe it's the goat
[Laughter]
all right quavo we have a crane segment
on our show called explain that graham
we do a deep dive on our guest instagram
pull interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story you
dig
all right so here you are performing at
eurovision in tel aviv with madonna
and eurovision is this crazy event that
will draw literally hundreds of millions
of viewers
what was your impression of it and how
would you explain eurovision to a
confused american who's never heard of
it
uh eurovision is a spot it's crazy
uh with all the fans well everybody is
like
all over music and they just put so much
time and effort in they stay said or
something it's like a big grand finale
but
i feel like it was it was it was
something i wanted to be
i wanted to perform it because i think i
was the first rapper to ever perform
there
the next thing you know i started like
learning about it and then
will ferrell come out with a movie yeah
i was like damn i was there so
i feel like i needed to be a part of
that to be one of the greatest
musicians ever and i was on stage with
one of them
all right this next one do you have a
favorite memory or favorite game
from the handful that you've watched
from the sidelines with the georgia
bulldogs got to be that one
got to be that game right there that's
when we took it home we won xc we won
the sec championship we went on and got
the rose bowl
we beat baker mayfield um
then we lost a tough one in alabama but
i was i was there a whole step of the
way and i feel like
the boys was rocking out and they did a
good job did you do any uh
a halftime stuff any sort of like
pregame stuff
just some prep just cut some out get
them going
you know that's it can you give us just
one thing that was discussed at this
meeting of the minds it's an amazing
picture
you kanye west travis scott and elon
musk
yeah that was the day this cyber truck
that um
he had kind of like dropped the cyber
truck and teased it and that right that
was actually christmas
um the christmas party so we're just
spending time with the family and
chopping it up with elon and tell them
come on with that truck we need
back half here you said backhand we call
that the back end you don't come out
[Music]
kind of like a curry vibe
yeah curvy chicken
pretty hot now it's getting real back
end
it gets pretty real
so songwriters can be very particular
about the atmosphere or their
surroundings within a room
how would you describe the ideal
creative conditions for quavo
me myself and a computer mic and
keyboard
no engineer most of the time just in the
studio i treat the studio like a gym
she got my tongue but it's not
how i feel like i don't know what it is
i've heard stories rick ross for example
laying out spreads of fully cooked
steaks
not for eating but simply for the aroma
in the studio
what's like the most unique thing that
you've ever seen an artist do to set a
vibe in the studio
uh got to be dj khaled
the biggest vibe um
[Music]
uh i can't i can't even really speak
because my tongue is on fire
that's the show yeah that's the show
so he had i don't know i can't talk bro
like real all right so um he does it up
on the jet
the house he had tons of food tables
super long just
whatever food you could imagine we sat
out there and we ate really good we
after we ate we went to the studio and
made a smash go crazy
with her and i just feel like that was
the craziest vibe and it was a big hit
was that the same session that he was
blasting off the airhorn there you go
there you
go help me out cause i can't really talk
like that
can y'all just give me a fork oh that's
smart grab a fork
all right this one is love burns from
hotter than l
let's try your way
so it seems like your driveway has been
getting pretty crowded lately and i saw
that
last summer you put the santa slade
paint job on your new tesla
of all the cars in your garage which one
does have your favorite or the most
unique custom finish
tesla
[Music]
which italian manufacturer do you think
makes better luxury sports cars ferrari
or lamborghini and what
lamborghini lambo
hold on man hold up yeah it's a lot it's
a lot
darling where is going on with these
wings man
hold on man hey hold up
i can't get five seconds really somebody
give me five seconds man
we can slow it down that's what i'm
saying like when you ask them a question
you feel like you're getting hotter bro
when you stop it's i'm good yeah yeah we
just chill here we can just chill
[Music]
what was that again love burn love burns
yeah
love burns real
all right we finna go to the
bomb if you're ready for that they got a
nuclear weapon
it's like they got a nuclear bomb on it
i ain't a lot like i love still burning
i'm just kick back because i know what
it's gonna do what the [ __ ]
is going on this is a wild one
[Music]
it's wild
they're the last one y'all
oh man
[Music]
who made this house my boy so this
actually comes out of kansas city
kansas city missouri what it's a crazy
sauce
and she got me this is crazy
actually they made me cry boy
that's hot yeah yeah yeah that was hot
i know i know she's still hot it's a
it's a
weird show i know
what
[Music]
i got to pull out the set
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that
all right all right we're back i'm
having fun
okay trust me it's just that bomb they
bombed me
oh my god all right are you ready to
move on here
sauce yeah no more sauce
the bomb is the last one for me and it
bonded me
it happens he did what he's supposed to
do actually yeah that [ __ ] crazy
[Music]
and i'll just ask you some questions and
then we'll finish this thing up does
that sound good
that sounds perfect so one of your many
hidden talents is that of an athlete in
fact
i understand that you led gwinnett
county in passing yards as a senior
quarterback at birkmar high school
did you get any feedback on your
throwing mechanics when you made that
visit to the university of michigan back
in 2018
no they just told me i needed a living
my zip with the whip
so athletes often use music for
inspiration i know this puts you on the
spot but what do you think is the best
migos song
for a locker room anthem before the big
game i just trade a game
for ice trade trae young in the playoffs
right now we need them to get to the
back
and then got to be straightening don't
none get straight and bust straightening
got to handle your business
all right so cuevo here we are
thankfully mercifully at the end of our
spicy wing journey together
and i'm not sure if you're aware of this
or not but a few years ago
offset came in and provided some of the
biggest spice highlights that we had in
all of season eight
so what i wanna do is show you some of
these highlights some of these gifs
widely circulated on the internet and as
someone who knows him best
i'm just curious what you think his
internal dialogue is okay
it wasn't that handled that yeah
all right up next
[Applause]
i don't know what he do
i think that was after the wedding
no oh that's after the bomb he ain't
doing it no more well he gotta beat him
he did continue to go on he did continue
to go on but he was pushed up against
the ropes
well there you have it cuevo the hot
ones experience in all of its glory
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
culture 3. culture 3 is the biggest
album of the world
going to be the greatest album of the
world and um we back with my brothers
see you on the stage near you you did
hey what's going on spice lords camera
guy bill here with a very special
announcement
june 14th is right around the corner and
do you know what that means flag day and
what better way to celebrate flag day
than by showing your hot ones pride with
some brand new
hot ones flags from buffalo's very own
oxford pennant
from the birthplace of the chicken wing
and the show that made eating the
hottest sauce is known to man a global
sensation comes a collaboration for the
ages
the oxford pennant hot ones collection
is spice load approved and sean evans
certified
your favorite hot one systems are
immortalized in a series of pennants
camp flags banners and pins fully
designed and manufactured in my hometown
the spiciest city in america
buffalo new york if there's one thing i
love about buffalo
it's that it's giving you such national
treasures as the chicken wing
the buffalo bills tony soprano's mom
rick james camera guy bill and the
hottest collaboration of the year
get yours today at
shop.firstweekfeast.com that's
shop.firstweekfeast.com happy flag day